[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
feurig und moral sind gerade in der
türkei machen oder und haben gedacht
kaum mitmachen doch ein video
denn wir wollen heute was machen ein
banales genau das haben wir jetzt selber
als amira ist ziemlich verrückt und bei
der asse wird einigen tag morgens
mittags abends dann einsetzen wenn es
gehen würde oder nach dem essen gestern
genau deswegen heute unser eis zelger
und ich sage wir es einfach kostet
zutaten ich habe jetzt gleich eine alte
maschine aber ihr könnt das ganze auch
ohne einfach schiene machen denn dieses
banane lies wird das thema server cremig
und ich find's super war kann es selber
machen das sind zutaten also ganz
natürliche zutaten es geht super schnell
und schmeckt richtig gut
wir brauchen dafür 400 gramm bananen ich
habe jetzt hier richtig schöne reife
bananen erkennt man daran dass eben die
schale schon etwas braun ist und die
sind eben richtig schön süß und
schmecken eben auch freistil gut 250
gramm puderzucker 50 milliliter milch
und 200 gramm oder 100 milliliter
schlagsahne
wir sind jetzt in der türkei hier ist es
ganze krämer und ich muss dazu sagen
dass ich hier viermal so teuer wie in
deutschland also in deutschland zahle
ich für so ein bisschen sahne vielleicht
45 zahl ich wir fast fünf lehrer und das
ist fasten euro 50 euro für so ein
projekt natürlich echt teuer und bauen
doch eine drohne ganz genau
jetzt kommt direkt starten erstens ist
die bananen und scheren die
guck mal hier weil die schale ist alles
schön sauber bleibt und dann gebe ich
dir sagen wo ist nichts gefäß und
pyridin gleich also wenig an mixa hat
zum beispiel in der kälte oder mit der
ganz schnell können ist einfach mixen
ich habe jetzt hier nur ein pürierstab
deswegen mache ich das nicht statt
es war noch ein paar immer noch drei
stück und die sind ja echt lecker also
ich finde ich sie noch ganz anders aus
also richtig guter moment automatik auf
ganz frisch nach schön doch der leckeres
obst die einen noch genau
und jetzt kuriere ich diana ganz klein
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich den zitronensaft mit rein
erzählt citrus presse
aber das mache ich jetzt so mit der hand
nimmt die kerne vorher aus dieser
melange kurzweg die geht es draußen
schwimmen zwei ihr wissen zum war hier
drin und wenn ihr möchtet könnt jetzt in
sache der ganzen zitrone oder eingeben
ich bin das total lecker was einfach
auch etwas säuerlicher schmeckt wer
möchte kann aber auch eine spritze mit
rein geben also wer lieber mit prinz
harry war einfach nur so eine spritze
ist eine rein möchte
denn kern nämlich kurz raus und dann
müsste auch ganz schnell arbeiten also
durch den zitronensaft wird einfach
verlängert das die banane schnell frauen
wird und das wird das darf man das eben
vor es müsste auch ziemlich schnell
arbeiten damit die bagger nicht noch
gerne werden
und jetzt gebe ich einfach die
restlichen zutaten mit rein also milch
dann auch dieses grammer und falls jetzt
das ganze wega machen wollt weil ihr
habt ihr gesehen da ist kein ei mit drin
wie jetzt beim basis rezept dann könnte
das auch machen ihr müsst einfach nur
statt der milch und der saane etwas
kokosmilch zum beispiel nehmen oder
sojamilch oder habe mich also irgendwas
anderes
ich glaube ich könnte mir auch mangel
vorliegen man die menschen dort ist er
schmeckt nach richtig gut
oder diese haselnuss mensch dies auch
ziemlich lecker kann man natürlich dann
auch direkt die den geschmacks ein
bisschen variieren habe ich so im
internet
das geht doch noch mit rein und der zug
also die bananen sind war an sich schon
süß genug und ihr könnt es jetzt auch
schon mal abschmecken
aber wenn das alles gleich gefriert dann
verliert sich die süße deswegen müsst
ihr beim abspecken darauf achten dass
jetzt die master etwas süßer ist und
später wird sie dann eben dass sie muss
also kommen da einfach weniger süßes ich
gebe jetzt aber wahrscheinlich den
ganzen zucker mit rein wenn man mal
laktosefrei möglich gemacht da kann man
es auch natur so genau wenn man diese
frage nicht ganz alle drei machen also
das ist wirklich ein super rezept
eigentlich für alle geeignet sind jedoch
davon aus mit dem bagger mit taliban
haben wir diese eigenschaft das ist so
schön cremig werden dem 1
deswegen brauchen wir jetzt auch kein 1
so und das war es auch schon meine eis
mine eyes grundrezept ist es praktisch
werde ich diese grund machte und jetzt
mache ich hier ganz kurz augen den
vorsatz für die kitchenaid also die
kühltheken die eismaschine und dafür
muss dann schon fragen geben also meine
arbeit ist jetzt erledigt und danach
erschienen
und wenn man keine angst machen und über
keine ein verstehen die macht kam und er
sieht zum beispiel seines faches gefäß
für habe ich hier zum beispiel auch
schon gewusst als also abgefilmt da war
ich nicht schnell genug mit denen mit
der zitrone also dieses ein bisschen
brauner geworden ist aber auch nicht hin
und es sind einfach in das gefrierfach
stellen und dass wir dann trotzdem
cremig ihr könnt natürlich auch ab und
zu mal durch füllen unseren vier bis
sechs stunden müsste es dann gefroren
sein also das bereichs so alles ab und
zu ja alle stunde muss durch röhren und
dann hab dann sowas
also das heißt je früher schon zu cremig
als ich dann einfach alles wieder schön
verbindet am besten im schnee lesen
kommt gut durch am anfang zumindest am
ende nicht mehr da bist du vielleicht
ein holzlöffel und hat sie im silicon
schaber nehmen und da hab dann kreisen
habe ich vor dass conti küchenmaschine
die eismaschine und zeige ich euch das
wesentliche
also das ist der eisfelder dabei mehr
über nacht ihren der gefriertruhe und im
sommer würde ich diese gewissensfrage
das immer im gefrierfach zu behalten
weil er einfach immer schnell als man
könnte also das mit der masse hat jetzt
vielleicht etwas gedauert 50 minuten
und jetzt würde ich das gleiche
schreiben und dann habe ich etwa in
zwanzig dreißig minuten mein eis je
nachdem wie die außentemperatur eben
auch ist also hier ist da war ich noch
da ich die kinder das klimagerät an
aber da habe das superschnelle selbst
gemachtes eis und da gibt's jetzt
einfach diesen vorfall nicht weiter oben
mit reinhängen und dann kommt dieses
frühe elemente mit rein sagte das wollte
man muss es einfach so schön das drauf
passen
kurz mit dem wirklich so
und das ist übrigens auch mein set jetzt
über den sommer
da gibt's nämlich die kitchenaid mit
rücktritten mit der ein china also bin
ich halt richtig gut und ich habe
gedacht das passt einfach super und hat
das mit der hand gegeben so jetzt
schneidet die küchenmaschine ab stufe
eins und das ist es also schaffen
wichtig dass er erst an macht und dann
eben rein damit sich das nicht für jedes
team wir eben die auf kosten von 20 bis
35 minuten etwa dürren sieht jetzt noch
relativ wenig aber sind eben schon für
sich aber wenig als es reicht sogar aber
das sehen sie selbst was denn die
flüssigkeit drin in dem sich einfach
keiner aus deswegen wird das volumen
mehr auf diesen machen wir
august ergebnis so sieht das eisen sich
bereits nach fünf minuten aus als man
sie deutlich es wird schon cremiger und
man sieht auch dass es anfängt zu
gefrieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mein rechtstipp fertig und es hat
ungefähr 25 minuten gedauert hat genau
auf die uhr geschaut und jetzt zeige ich
euch mal die konsistent also sieht es in
etwa aus dem munde sich gerade alle
wegen dem boden oh ja übrigens meine
meinung dass ich meine gerade
verabschiedet also deswegen mache ich
das gerade über das kamera mikrofon
aber ich habe eben auch nur
funktionieren aber zwischen leider eine
leichte veränderung also selbst das krad
aus und ihr müsst jetzt auf jeden fall
darauf achten dass sie jetzt nicht mit
einem spitzen gegenstand da reingeht
also auch keine löffel mix aus metall
sondern am besten mit was aus silikon
da können dann nämlich die form auch
nicht kaputt machen und so wie gesagt
jetzt hat sich das eisvolumen zumindest
vermehrt und noch viel mehr würde ich
auch damit nicht heim geben weil
ansonsten der ist gar nicht schafft also
dann wird irgendwann das gefäß warm und
ich finde sich die perfekte konsistenz
ich das jetzt mal
jetzt ist so wie es oft 1 jetzt möchte
dass es noch fester wird kann es einfach
noch mal kurz einfrieren das mache ich
jetzt schnell weil ich habe jetzt zu
hause gerade ungefähr 30 grad
und ich möchte jetzt ein bisschen
stadtfesten wird monatlich noch kurz und
eislaufen nachbarn aus und dann zeige
ich euch gleich wie ich das eis
servieren
es schmeckt lecker ist schon probiert
ich geh jetzt sind zum zum nachbarn
äußern
okay ich hatte meinen 19 gefrieren war
ich hatte sogar über nacht sind wir
jetzt auch in einem anderen outfit werde
ich jetzt schon einfach nicht mehr
geschafft
vor allem was sich dann auch irgendwann
weg oder habe ich gern macht schläger
mal grün
außerdem kann ich euch so zeigen wie das
iphone über nacht aussieht und es hat
mir richtig schöne konsistenz also man
sieht ich kann es mit einem eislöffel
richtig schöner kugeln kamen wobei die
ausverkaufsware ist das netz ist okay
also kriegt eiskugeln hin sagt ich muss
aber ist sie richtig schön cremig
arbeiten ist halt auch bedenken das eis
schmilzt ist natürlich auch schneller
alles was er gekauft habe war das sind
ja diese stoffe nicht drin die das eis
dann eben auch bei zimmertemperatur noch
eine gewisse zeit lang fest beiden
machen soll ist weder ein spiel muss man
auch aus rein machen ansonsten könnte
das ja gar nicht verkaufen waren tragen
weil alles zu starten
a
vor allem so erfrischend ich finde auch
grad wende zum beispiel tagsüber fastet
was jetzt gerade für alle die jetzt auf
beim ramadan und eben mit wachstum
felix am abend echt perfekt das könnt
ihr morgen ist so bereiten ins
gefrierfach geben bis zum abend ist
schon richtig perfekt und da hab da
einfach nur richtig leichter erfrischung
mit bananen etwas sahne und milch also
für mich 18 perfekteste richtig schön
bei mir gibt es noch einfacher cottbus
mit 1 wer möchte könnte jetzt auch etwas
schoko store ist mit rein geben
und jetzt noch mal bist du dick
hochrhein
ich glaube ich ganz gut aus unsere sitz
in den keller
ihr könnt ihr übrigens diese chance auch
mit inside gegen finde ich auch lecker
da habt ihr nämlich die mit tritten und
können weiß dann dass schön drauf und
ich will diese zweite variante ohne
eismaschine die hatte ich das so einfach
ins gefrierfach gestellt und ich habe
sie nicht mal durch gerührt also ich hab
das komplett vergessen habe es nicht
durchgeführt bayern vertrieb gestärkt
und hier könnt ihr 18
es ist etwas fester in der konsistenz
aber man kriegt trotzdem gut raus also
ich würde es jetzt ein paar minuten
draußen stehen lassen dann kann man es
auch formen aber wenn ich das jetzt
durch gerührt hätte dazu eine jede
stunde einmal dann werde ich natürlich
auch etwas wahr geworden
ja das war ein schnelles eis ritter ich
hoffe dass es euch gefällt und ist nach
macht und ich schreibe euch das rezept
auch zu lesen ist buffed.de da kann es
dann gerne nachmachen und mir auf jeden
fall ein foto auf facebook oder auf
dienstag beim kicken und wegen immer
ganz einfach nächsten mal wieder befragt
[Musik]